ام وليد سيده جزائريه اسمها مو غريب على
الجزائريين ولكن شكلها مجهول وغامض
بالنسبه للكل بما فيهم متابعيها يعني ما
هي فزوره فام وليد هي صاحبه قناه او صاحبه
قناه ام وليد على يوتيوب ومتخصصه بالطبخ
وبتعرف عن نفسها انها قناه خاصه بالطبخ
السهل بمقادير مضبوطه خاصه لكل مبتدئه
ولكل امراه وعلى القناه في 11 مليون و700
الف مشترك واكثر من مليارين ونصف مشاهده
هدول كلهم جمعتهم ام وليد عشان يتابعوا
فيديوهاتها للطبخ اللي ما بتبان هي فيها
وما بيسمعوا الناس الا صوتها وبيشوفوا
الوصفات
السلام عليكم يا جماعه وصفات ام وليد هذه
الوصفه اللي خفيفه شوفوا مقادير قليله
حضرت بهم زوج وخبيزات بهذه الطريقه نكورو
غير شويه شويه لانه كيما تلاحظوا شويه
بارد بهذه الطريقه اذا ها هو الباذنجان
بعد ما حمرته في الفوق شوفوا
ام وليد تفاجات الناس هذا الموسم الرمضاني
بدخول مجال الاعلام وطلت على البرنامج في
برنامج طبخ سمته الفضاء ام وليد على قناه
سميره تي في لكن برضو من غير ما تكشف وشها
ام وليد كانت رمضان الماضي شاركت في فقره
طبخه على نفس القناه والسنه صارت مقدمه
البرنامج وفي بتستضيفيه فنانين ومشاهير
على متن مركبه فضائيه وبيحضروا او بيحضروا
خلال الحلقه وصفات متعدده ام وليد ثابته
على موقفها وما ظهرت ابدا وبتدير الحلقه
وهي جالسه في غرفه ثانيه وعبر الكاميرات
ومكبرات الصوت وحتى فريق القناه ما يعرف
شكلها لانها بتسجل الحلقات بنفسها وحقيقه
البرنامج لا قصدي احسان منقطع النظير على
المنصات وكثير من الناس الشادو بام وليد
اللي قدرت تحقق شهره كبيره من غير ما تظهر
للعلن